Britt Rae merci de m'avoir rejoint aujourd'hui
merci de m'avoir fait manquer Riley la
montée de la nécrofaune l'éthique scientifique
et les risques d'extension un
livre merveilleusement intéressant ce qui vous a poussé à
écrire ceci et à vous intéresser à ce
sujet merci
bien il y a de nombreuses années  probablement environ cinq
maintenant, j'ai entendu dire que les gens prenaient cette
idée au sérieux qu'ils pourraient
potentiellement ramener
à la vie des espèces éteintes et qu'ils étaient des gens ayant des liens profonds avec les
sociétés de séquençage génétique technologique et essentiellement des gens qui ont
le savoir-faire pour appliquer une
technologie de pointe à l'ancien  G vous connaissez les
animaux pour potentiellement faire quelque chose
comme ça et j'ai pensé oh wow d'accord ce
n'est absolument pas l'approche du contour à
laquelle je suis habitué parce que j'ai fait un diplôme
en biologie et je me suis concentré sur la conservation
et la façon dont les gens innovent de manière à ce
que  vous essayez de protéger les espèces en voie de
disparition et c'était quelque chose de
complètement nouveau et aussi potentiellement
préoccupant en termes de
conséquences involontaires  les uences qui pourraient provenir de
ce genre de travail ne
semblaient tout simplement pas réalistes, cela ressemblait à de la science-
fiction et je suis extrêmement curieux de savoir
comment les gens et pourquoi les gens prenaient
cela au sérieux, alors j'ai décidé de faire un
documentaire radio à ce sujet.
faire des documentaires à ce sujet et
cela m'a amené à être effectivement un
journaliste sur le terrain interviewant
qui était à la pointe de ce domaine à la
fois pour le projet de faire l'
extinction et contre lui et j'étais juste
très fasciné par ce qu'ils avaient à
dire  eh bien, en lisant ce livre, nous
disons souvent qu'il soulève autant de questions qu'il n'en
résout en lisant ce livre, il
semble lire qu'il soulève beaucoup plus de
questions qu'il ne pourrait éventuellement répondre,
oui, je pense que c'est
juste de dire que c'était quoi  J'ai remarqué
en enquêtant sur cette tentation de
ramener à la vie des espèces disparues, mais
plus je la regardais, plus
elle devenait beaucoup plus compliquée
qu'il
n'y paraissait au départ.  l'ambition scientifique
soit en raison des obstacles techniques
qui existaient avec les
technologies existantes, soit des réalités biologiques
du travail avec certaines des espèces et de
leur ancienne collection de génomes d'ADN
qui était disponible, soit des problèmes éthiques
de ce que cela signifierait si le scientifique
devait  réussir et ramener ces animaux
dans le monde, pourquoi seraient-ils
capables de ré-ensauvager les propriétaires
qu'ils espèrent ou ces animaux finiraient-ils
par vivre leur existence dans un zoo
est une sorte de curiosité captive qui
s'inscrit dans un laboratoire quelque part tout le
comment il interagit avec les valeurs humaines
et comment protéger ces animaux et
oui la liste est longue mais je suis
d'accord avec vous, cela ouvre plus de questions et de
réponses
jusqu'où en sommes-nous je sais dans
le livre qu'il mentionne des personnes essayant de
ressusciter  un ancien type de zèbre et
un ancien type de vache ou de bétail d'une
certaine sorte à quel point en sommes-nous sur ces
choses donc il y a différentes approches
à faire  g extinction et dans tous les cas,
il est en fait erroné de dire que le jour où l'
extinction peut ressusciter une
espèce éteinte dans le monde à la place, nous
pouvons créer de nouveaux animaux qui sont des
répliques proches ou des comparaisons factuelles d'
espèces éteintes et il y a une variété de
raisons différentes pour lesquelles mais ils aussi
concernent en grande partie la façon dont ces clés sont
fabriquées et il peut s'agir de clonage ou d'
ingénierie du génome ou dans les cas que vous avez
mentionnés, c'est la rétro-élevage qui est utilisée
pour essayer de vous recréer ou Rockland est
l'ancêtre éteint de tout le bétail d'aujourd'hui
ou le quagga qui était un
sous-espèce un zèbre que nous avons et avons encore
dans le monde mais il a l'air un
peu différent il avait un dos nu et
un pelage de couleur moka en dessous autre que
c'est la vie et donc dans ces deux cas nous
avons déjà des animaux qui
ressemblent beaucoup  comme l'oiseau éteint que des
groupes ont pu se reproduire et
qu'il existe un processus de reproduction qui implique un type de
processus de reproduction par lequel
la ou les chances, par exemple, nous savons que
thi  l'ancêtre éteint de tous
les bovins vivants d'aujourd'hui a été anéanti dans les années 1600,
mais que son génome est toujours
poivré parmi ses descendants, donc si vous
choisissez les lignées de bovins qui lui
ressemblent le plus, car elles ont la bonne
forme et la bonne taille de cornes et la bonne
relation de couleur  modèles ou le droit c'est
dans leur type de corps entre les mâles et les
femelles par exemple et vous créez des
lignées de reproduction et où vous croisez ensemble ces types de
bovins qui ressemblent le plus à celui qui a
disparu sur plusieurs générations, vous
pouvez réellement commencer à voir que vous pouvez
précisément faire  ces traits de
bétail éteint émergent dans les nouveaux animaux que
vous élevez, c'est donc une approche moins technologique
pour faire l'extinction D, alors ce que
certaines de ces techniques d'ingénierie ou de
clonage du génome peuvent nous donner, mais l'
idée est fondamentalement, vous savez si cela
ressemble  un canard et il cancane comme un canard
alors c'est un assez bon canard ou ou bœuf ou
quagga ou tout autre animal éteint que
vous pourriez essayer de reproduire à partir
du parent  des pommes vivantes que nous avons encore
aujourd'hui dans la terre et bien l'un des
arguments contre cela que vous avez
mentionné dans le livre est le fait qu'il
y a beaucoup d'argent dépensé pour
cela et divers types de recherche, mais
cet argent serait probablement mieux
dépensé pour  vers la conservation des
espèces existantes plutôt que d'essayer de ramener
une espèce qui a disparu il y a des centaines, des
milliers ou des millions d'années.
cela voudrait-il dire si l'
extinction devait prélever sur
les budgets de conservation tels qu'ils sont
actuellement mis en place pour aider les espèces en voie de disparition
dans la nature et détourner ces ressources
pour venir vers ces approches plus expérimentales
de la conservation en
essayant de ressusciter des génomes éteints, donc
ce n'est pas moi  je veux juste être clair à
ce sujet parce que ceux qui font l'
extinction sont à travers l'église de George
mais Harvard travaille sur le
mammouth laineux  ils disent que la plus grande chose
qui les retient est l'argent, c'est
qu'ils n'en ont pas une tonne parce que
c'est un projet parallèle de leur laboratoire
sinon ils ont la technologie là
-bas et ils pourraient travailler beaucoup plus vite
qu'ils ne le sont maintenant
il y a un  organisation appelée revivre
et restaurer essayant d'obtenir beaucoup plus d'
argent pour leur projet de désextinction
pour le champ d'extinction G dans son ensemble en
établissant des partenariats industriels avec
des laboratoires de biosciences de haute technologie afin
de passer du niveau de
recherche universitaire à quelque chose  cela peut en fait
être reproduit et avancé plus rapidement, mais
cela a empêché les gens de se demander si
cela pourrait nuire aux
ressources de conservation que nous avons déjà et en
fait et l'année dernière, un
article a été publié dans Nature dirigé par un
écologiste et économiste de la conservation
nommé Joseph  Bennett à l'Université
de Carleton à Ottawa et ils ont couru les
chiffres en regardant d'accord avec
les budgets de conservation réalistes de la Nouvelle-Zélande en
Austral  ia qui existent déjà
pour aider les espèces actuellement en voie de disparition et
si les budgets de conservation de ces
fonds étaient canalisés pour aider à
recréer des versions fermées de ces
espèces éteintes, qu'arriverait-il aux
espèces en voie de disparition pour lesquelles l'
argent était à l'origine là pour aider et
ils ont constaté que si le  l'extinction
prend de ces budgets de conservation
qu'ils auraient toujours pu sauver au
moins huit fois plus d'espèces s'ils l'
avaient laissé à la conservation
comme c'est traditionnellement le cas par rapport à l'
utilisation de l'argent pour pouvoir aider à
créer ces nouveaux types d'
animaux interrogateurs  que vous essayez de favoriser au
nom de DX changshun, donc fondamentalement, si
vous êtes intéressé par la conservation,
votre intérêt, leur argument était devrait
être une augmentation de la biodiversité nette, peu
importe ce que cela signifie,
donc la quantité d'animaux que vous
pouvez aider que vous pouvez  gardez leur
biodiversité car votre intérêt devrait être de
ne pas sélectionner des animaux intéressants
tels que le laineux  le mammouth ou la
tourte voyageuse ou le ou le bœuf ou
quel que soit votre exemple d'animal éteint,
car si vous pouvez aider plus d'
espèces actuellement en voie de disparition sur le
montant du nom, vous pourriez acheter la fabrication de
vêtements plutôt que la réparation d'espèces, vous ne faites pas
vraiment de faveur à la biodiversité
car là  sera une perte nette de biodiversité
, c'est une question comparative de
combien de bien vous pourriez faire avec le même
montant qu'en est-il de l'idée de
supposer que quelqu'un a en fait
disparu ou non des mammouths
et essaie de le réintroduire dans l'
environnement qu'est-ce que cela ferait  faire à l'
environnement, cela pourrait éventuellement forcer
une autre espèce existante à disparaître
et le mammouth laineux que
vous avez recréé va dans un
environnement qui est peut-être radicalement
différent de l'environnement dans lequel
l'animal d'origine vivait de toute façon c'est un
grand point et c'est  celui
qui apparaît comme un point de refoulement contre l'
extinction qui fonctionne sur une théorie de la
restauration écologique  ation cette idée étant
que si dans un écosystème vous pouvez localiser une
situation où il y avait un elle a eu un
rôle fonctionnel très important à
y jouer qui a ensuite disparu et une partie de
la dynamique de cet écosystème a disparu
lorsque cette espèce a disparu et vous
pouvez faire un  animal qui imite cet
animal éteint parce que vous ne pouvez pas le
ramener directement en l'intégrant à
l'animal, alors vous voulez le faire et le
remettre dans cet écosystème qui
a perdu une partie de sa
productivité importante, l'idée étant que
vous le restaureriez  et ramener quelque
chose de fonctionnellement bénéfique dans
cet écosystème que c'est vraiment euh
vous savez que c'est un test et étrange pour de nombreux défenseurs de l'
environnement certainement parce que les
écosystèmes sont juste en attente
une fois que certaines espèces disparaissent et
s'éteignent, ce n'est pas seulement attendre violemment
que quelque chose se produise, c'est de  bien sûr
s'adapter à cette perte et cela
avance dans le temps de l'évolution, créant ainsi
une sorte d'animal qui ressemble à un
a  nimal qui aurait pu être là il y a
dix mille ans et le
réintroduire n'aura pas nécessairement cet effet
détournant l'environnement vers ce qu'il était
autrefois, cela pourrait créer un nouveau
tertiaire ou vous savez une situation totalement nouvelle
que le monde n'a pas vue
mais vous avez mentionné le mammouth laineux et
c'est un cas vraiment intéressant car
ce n'est pas très évident au début de se
rendre compte que la raison pour laquelle ils veulent recréer
le mammouth laineux a à voir avec le
changement climatique et l'atténuation de ses
effets néfastes parce que si vous pensez à
où  le mammouth laineux avait l'habitude de
bien courir et l'endroit pour sembler des endroits comme
le U au Canada, ainsi que la Sibérie et la
Russie, il existe d'énormes lois terrestres
qui ne contiennent que du pergélisol et le
pergélisol contient d'énormes quantités
de carbone parce qu'il y a eu tous
ces animaux  des millénaires qui y sont
morts et sont tombés dans le sol,
mais plus important encore, toute cette végétation
dont ils se sont nourris et qui
vient d'être en t  L'environnement est
enfermé dans ces sols et tout est fait de
carbone, mais nous avons appris que le pergélisol
est en fait un mauvais terme pour ces sols
car ils ne sont pas gelés en permanence,
il s'avère avec les effets du
changement climatique dans le réchauffement que nous '  re voyant que
ces réservoirs de carbone fondent le dégel du
pergélisol puis laissent ce
carbone se libérer dans l'atmosphère ce qui
devient très dangereux quand on se rend compte
qu'il y a deux fois plus de carbone
emprisonné dans ces sols et qu'il est
actuellement déjà dans l'atmosphère et
qu'il y a des microbes partout  qui peut
transformer ce carbone en méthane ou en dioxyde de
carbone à quel point le vert a la santé comment
le mammouth laineux changerait-il
cela si vous le réintroduisiez là-bas
qu'est-ce qu'ils supposent que cela en profite donc il y
avait plus d'animaux qu'il n'y en a
maintenant mais il y a une extinction de la mégafaune
qui s'est produite  pour sortir le
mammouth laineux ainsi que de nombreuses autres espèces
et si vous pensez à ces zones
qui ont moins d'anima  l productivité en
eux maintenant pendant une grande partie de l'année, ils sont
recouverts de neige et de neige qui peuvent agir
comme une épaisse couverture isolante qui
garde les choses au chaud sur le sol
et ils le seraient autrement par
exemple si vous aviez des millions d'animaux en
cours d'exécution  autour de percer des trous dans la
neige afin que vous puissiez imaginer avoir de nombreux
mammouths laineux qui courent avec
leurs gros pieds de mammouth perforant cette
couverture isolante qui crée ces
trous permettant
qu'ils viennent de l'atmosphère pour descendre
et frapper le haut des sols et
fondamentalement  ils agiraient comme des
systèmes de ventilation mobiles est la théorie qui
court pour garder les choses plus froides et
concevoir cet environnement d'une manière
qui n'est pas sans la perturbation de
beaucoup de volonté, madame, par exemple, c'est un
peu loin pour certaines personnes d'
accepter  ça mais nous publions des nombres de
quatre-vingt mille mammouths laineux pour essayer
d'avoir une sorte d'effet bien je suis
juste curieux Brit Reyes est un
chercheur scientifique auteur et  c'est et ainsi de suite Je suis
juste curieux de savoir quelle est votre opinion
après avoir fait cette recherche sur ce que les
gens disent et font quelle est
votre opinion sur cette idée de l'extinction des
animaux Je pense que c'est un
projet technologique fascinant Je pense qu'il conduit
un  beaucoup d'émerveillement, d'émerveillement et d'imagination
pourquoi les gens sont si attirés par cette
impossibilité apparemment d'amener des
espèces éteintes dans le monde et cela motive
une grande partie de la science, mais je pense que
quand il s'agit de conservation,
il y a quelque chose qui ne s'additionne pas
là c'est le premier  et avant tout une
étape humaine technologique soignée intéressante mais ce n'est pas ce dont nous avons besoin pour résoudre
la crise environnementale la sixième
extinction massive d'espèces que nous sommes
actuellement et ce n'est pas la réponse à
la crise de la biodiversité que certaines personnes
attrapent c'est mon opinion personnelle  oui
après tout ce que j'ai appris
bien Britt ray merci beaucoup c'est
un livre des plus intéressants un
regard très intéressant sur un aspect de la science
e  beaucoup de gens ne sont pas au courant de ce qui
se passe en ce moment alors merci
beaucoup pour cela merci beaucoup
merci pour votre intérêt